uh what so tell me about smack that
because you said that that's the only
song that dropped that you didn't
produce did Eminem send you that beat no
no actually when I went to um visit him
in Detroit he was like so how you what
you want to do I say am I want to do
whatever you want to do I want you I
want to come into your world like yeah
because if I bring into my world it
won't be no different from what's out
there now right he's like all right well
you know I got some beats I said [ __ ]
you produce he said yeah I said well
play me some tracks he gave me a photo
with like 30 tracks on it and out of the
30 I picked five and out of five I
recorded all five but the one that stood
out smack that smack that yeah I was
like bro this is it are you I was gonna
say are you still actively doing the
production thing oh yeah that's yeah
that that never changed you know like a
lot of the records that you got that
you're hearing out now we got something
to do with you and Eminem here smack
that it gets laid down are you there
when he records his verses um well
actually once he heard my concept to it
then he was like yo I'm jumping on this
one yeah and I said you know what if he
jumps on this one this is the single oh
it was the same
and sure because that was your record
right that wasn't his record yeah that
was my record yeah do you guys had more
than one record or just one that's the
only one we had together yeah besides
the other five that didn't yeah but I
still have them oh wow that's like I
literally still have those records today
is there any songs that never dropped
that you have on a hard drive that you
were like man if this would ever came
together the right way those are all the
records that's gonna drop in the future
like did I that I'm promoting now these
are all records that was recorded that I
knew for a fact was Smash Hits but I
didn't want it was reasons why I didn't
drop them at that time and the time and
also made a difference too also like you
make Timeless records so it doesn't
matter it don't even matter but if you
turn on the radio right now you might
hear I want to love you or you might
want to you might hear I mean [ __ ] maybe
I'm back where it depends on what part
of the country you're definitely gonna
hear Soul Survivor no for sure yeah yeah
do you I feel like Soul Survivor did so
much for Jeezy because obviously had and
then what which I think was the first
single off tm101
um but it was like it was it was a dope
Club record dope Street record but to me
Soul Survivor just changed the whole
narrative because there was this guy who
everyone knew was the street rapper he
was in boys in the hood right and he he
had an undeniable hit record like Soul
Survivor is probably one of my favorite
hooks you've ever done like that record
a special man no it is special and you
made the beat yep that beats crazy
that's one of your best beats too
reliably that shit's hard yeah it's one
of the ones